tony blair during the iraq war was  talking about digital ids everything is  an opportunity right everything's an  opportunity to take control government  control and that's essentially what's  happening and for the very first time we  have an option a way to opt out money is  the center of everything if they don't  have your money they can't do anything  the bank controls everything right if  you don't deposit your money with the  bank then they have absolutely no  ability to do anything to you whether  it's push you deeper into poverty  through inflation  confiscate your money whatever it is  because you hold bitcoin